in the U.S the former Vice President of
the United States Mike Pence will
announce he is running for the
presidency in 2024 at an event next week
Pence was vice president under Donald
Trump of course from 2016 to 2020. let's
speak to our U.S correspondent in
Washington DC for us this evening Mark
Stone and and Markham uh traditionally
uh very conservative Mike Pence and
that's why he's picking to make the
announcement in Iowa
uh yes and to be clear it's no surprise
at all that he is um uh throwing his hat
in the ring he has been um given so many
hints over the course of the past 18
months or so that that he would be a
presidential candidate um a republican
candidate for the White House and so he
is that announcement um uh will formally
come on next Wednesday the 7th of June
in Des Moines Iowa Iowa uh where uh he
will um become yet another Republican uh
to join what is now a growing field
Donald Trump of course the clear
favorite uh to be the Republican
candidate followed by Ron DeSantis Nikki
Haley Chris Christie Tim Scott uh ASA
Hutchinson uh all of these figures and a
few others have now said that they want
to be uh the Republican nominee for
president of course the problem that all
of them have got
um with the exception of Donald Trump is
how to beat him he is the clear favorite
um how do they uh appeal to his base
which remains very very loyal very very
strong 30 or so of the um of the party
support him uh sorry 30 of the
electorate uh support him according to
polls so how do others appeal to that
base uh without alienating uh them um
it's clear that uh Once Upon a Time Mike
Pence and Donald Trump clearly had a
very close relationship it fell out
spectacularly
um over the course of the January the
sixth protests when uh uh vice president
uh Pence did go to the capital
um to um uh to effectively hand over
power to the new Administration against
the wishes of Donald Trump that's where
their relationship fell out but it's
interesting that Pence has not overtly
or explicitly criticized the former
president Trump since then he's going to
have to start doing that if he wants to
uh to try and raise his profile as the
as one of the Republican Party
candidates for president